This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
Christina,
here we are. Yeah, we are face to face.
Do you know the song?
A couple of silver spoons.
There's a, it's a really exciting
episode. We've got great guests, Kevin.
I don't want to sound excited.
That's my level of excitement. You always
make fun of me for that. It's so true.
I think that is your
general level of excitement.
You've never really gone off the rails.
Like I said before, the during the ads,
like tell him he sold out the wheel
turn. You're like, yeah, that's cool.
Tell him I'm having a baby.
Yeah, that's great. Tom,
watch this video of a guy getting his
legs crushed. What? Then you're excited.
Well that's good stuff. Yeah, no,
I've seen you get excited.
I'm watching football like that's
probably the most I've seen you. Yeah, go,
go nuts. Yeah. I mean I get
excited about like free candy.
Every candy's exciting, all cheeseburger
and I though, oh my goodness. You know?
Yeah.
Is You keep it inside.
I mean I think what happens
is I'm comfortable in a,
uh,
a certain,
in a certain bandwidth of that of
excitement and I don't allow myself to get
excited in fear of maybe what that will
feel like or maybe being disappointed by
that feeling. Huh. I'm sure
that's healthy. Right? I Dunno.
Heres your joy. As long as
you know, it gives you joy.
I know as long as something
gives you joy. Oh for sure. Yeah.
Ah,
oh yeah.
Yeah.
Tell Him we're having another baby.
My flat as a pancake and Yup.
Ah,
yeah. It's good stuff. It's about right.
What's interesting, Huh? Well I know what
makes me excited and I know it helps me.
Murder. What were you watching last
night? It was another Spanish show. No,
I didn't want to just be a no, no, no.
Okay. I watched, remember the, the,
we played it a long time ago.
These poor girls in Belize who were like,
I booked through the hammock. I
watched that documentary. Oh cool.
And it's about John McAfee,
the guy who started the McAfee
antivirus software. Crazy.
Cause he doesn't look like a programmer.
Like does this guy work for vice?
Like he looks like a photographer
that takes pictures of,
I was like [inaudible] guy's name.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like a cool photographer or
something. You're like, yeah,
that was wild.
I know he's got six different hair
colors in his hair and he's got crazy
shoulder tats and yeah,
he's having to go shit in his mouth.
Oh Gosh. Why did I forget that?
That's what we just said in his mouth.
I just thought like just shit through
a hammock and then just kind of shit on
and around his mouth. No, and around, no,
I just thought it meant around the mouth.
I didn't really think he did.
They say they said in his mouth and he
eats the Pupa or he just, and by the way,
that's the only thing he wanted with them.
That's a deep fetish because
they asked the girl were like,
did they ever have traditional,
gradual said, oh no, no,
no, no, no, just poofed. And she was like,
yeah, I like how that's offensive. Great.
I'm not going to have sex with this guy.
Crazy.
And she was talking about how it's her
first time ever doing something like that.
And then one lady was like,
I was really turned off by that.
But what an easy gig. I mean, if
you're going to be a prostitute,
I figured that's kind of one of
the Kush or gigs. I think so. Yeah,
I think so. Wow. You want
to see if I can pull it up?
That's a very specific
fetish. My goodness. I mean,
talk about the level of self awareness.
You'd have to have to really
figure that one out for yourself.
You mean you really have to be
brave to be like, you know what,
I think I want to, I think I want people
to shit in my mouth. Yeah. I mean that,
that for me would be so deeply
repressed sexually in my mouth.
Like why don't you just repress that
impulse like your whole life and never
allow it to happen? I would
never let myself indulge in
that one. It's real crazy.
Let's see if I can get this ready for you.
I don't think I could indulge it.
I don't think it's safe.
It's definitely not safe.
She did all the girls name.
Nice.
They're beautiful and the right
stuff the girls want to hear.
I think there will stay there for
the money at first and then, um,
most of them eventually I had
real true feelings for him.
No,
they're yellow too.
It was exciting for them living in this
big house and having chips and stuff
that they wouldn't normally would have
if there didn't meet Mr John drew ever
lived like that before?
No.
Had you ever had sex for
money prior to that or no,
but those were first time I was ashamed,
but then I got used to it.
What did the girl sit down?
This hallmark,
they have my card as a
whole and Patina Hamar.
After that he lays on the hallmark.
Then he m
he would've don't be shy
now and he would sit there.
That's what he used it cause he,
he wanted to have like
Scott Sec then on that.
I didn't agree with that.
What has got sex and when you [inaudible]
and he used to make you should and Mrs
Mouth. There she goes. She
loves it, but she's accepted it.
She's like never had done that before.
And yeah,
most people aren't told an
experience for a man. Yeah,
I seem to shit in his mouth.
Did he ever have regular
intercourse? Vaginal and knows. Wow.
Easy Kid.
That was only thing I did get.
The girls are lucky. I think
I was grateful because I
wanted to finish school.
I wanted to take the shit.
He was helping me so I didn't care
about what he did. I had to go anyway.
So I figure why not going
the Hammock and nice mine.
But you know what I want to know from
us. Got in person. How do you stop?
How do you keep from
vomiting? I don't know. Um,
that trigger not threat,
right?
Like they must enjoy the smells
and the hotness of it and the,
you know what's so funny? This
reminds me of the piss on me. Beat me.
Try it out guy. This is
the same principle. It's
like, do you want free rent,
free rent? All you have to do
is sit in this hammock. Yeah.
It's kind of a great deal.
I mean,
if I were one of these girls
and I ran this country,
I had no options and some white guys like,
do you want to shit in this hammock?
And my mom's like, yeah, absolutely. Do
I start? If you want to watch the full,
that's a good documentary.
The dangerous life of John McAfee.
It's on Netflix. Wait, but if
you were a troubled, you know,
like a girl who needed
what I do this of course,
of course I would was silly question.
The only thing I think would be really
hard for me is the first time when you're
trying to relax and to doing it and
then like by the 10th time it's second
nature. But that first time
it's gotta be the hardest.
What if you have a real slopper
coming out the first time even better?
I don't know.
Do you think he needs a certain,
like a Bristol number for him to
be into it? Like four or five?
I think he probably wants like a four.
Yeah.
Most people do like an easy,
but if you really grind
one out and you're like,
and you grind your teeth and he's like,
he's like oof.
And he can see it slowly come
out and it's like, uh, you know,
like a, like an old Plato hard.
But if you have a real blaster,
like it just play a diarrhea. And this
is what country, oh, this isn't beliefs.
Did you see that all the
time? Fed that tweet? Uh,
people send it to me and this girl is
tweet went viral where she is in the
bathroom and she's just like trying
to look in the mirror and she's in the
women's bathroom.
She's filming herself and as she like
does this and is looking at her hair, uh,
a woman takes a ferocious done.
She's like,
it's so ferocious.
It's a woman's dump.
Yesterday at the airport.
I had the experience of,
I landed at lax and the woman in the
stall next to me how to full speakerphone
conversation in Spanish while she was
taking had a really crazy thing while she
was taking a dob. A full answer on speaker
phone. No less. It's really crazy. Yeah.
I'm, I'm amazed that people's audacity
course. God, aren't you fucking,
I mean to quote Sebastian, aren't
you embarrassed? Gotcha. Oh, my life.
Let me see if I can,
I want to pull this up for you because
I laughed so hard and thought about,
you know,
here it is John.
I live in the house and all I
have to do is poop in the hammock.
Here it is here.
Oh my goodness.
Uh, for women it's a great, it's a
big deal. If we're guys are like,
what's the big deal? I see
that. And they're like,
you can see she's like crazy. Yeah. Well
most women don't let it go like that.
Really know.
You Kinda,
you clench and you let it out piece by
piece so that it doesn't make sound.
You're embarrassed.
Women are embarrassed of their bodies.
And their body functions.
Not like dudes.
Why are you guys so open that I
want to know what the differences,
why is it testosterone?
Maybe there's just less shame.
What's up with the show properly? Oh
my God, we haven't even done that yet.
Keep telling me to go next hammock.
If you paid any kind of a
wreck now. Yes, order problems.
I'm here to tell you forget that
bag or forget about Sally's.
Forget that Dick and
plants and all that stuff,
so I don't know if you believe me or not.
You like the same.
You smoked some meth with a small limp.
Dick.
Did Dad get hardly any other way and why?
G A harder and harder. I smoke harder.
My Dick get,
that's fine.
We'll go to your mom's house.
Did you hear that part? What do you,
because you saw you go like, I don't know.
I heard smoking meth.
Yeah. Yeah. He's like,
forget about Viagra hours. Yeah,
that's what you heard. Yeah.
If you want to really get hard, he's
like, smoke meth. I never heard that.
You can watch me watch my little limp.
Dick gets super hard with
the more meth I smoke.
They were not
to.
Dick didn't get hardly any other way and
watch it get harder and harder. More.
I smoke no harder. My Dick get
this. Unbelievable. You Gay.
You won't believe how good it feels.
If you're straight,
you won't believe how good it feels.
You're dickhead becomes hope
sensitive that you don't need lube.
You don't need spit you this.
This happened down four times.
It's just barely do it and
you will shoot an enormous
thick,
hot,
well,
what am I barfed Jesus.
This guy reminds me of
the 10 to 12 Benadryl
sat atop Benadryl guy.
His base code is math.
That's what Judy said.
Hold on,
let me put this on the drooling.
What?
Remember
what part? What's your favorite part
right now and that you're Super India.
He's just too cool.
Yeah.
Just Sharon is beauty tips.
Sharing the story. Yeah.
It's a nice story,
right? Oh, there's more.
I Dunno. Can we just pause like I
feel like, no, I can't. I can't.
I can't stop, but I can't. First of all,
oh my God.
Can we just say one thing now that he
meets the criteria of a fantastic your
mom's house video. First of
all, the lighting is dog shit.
He's got the ceiling in the background,
the white facing up this true.
Um,
you can barely see his face
because he's lit so poorly.
He hits all the boxes for a perfect video.
Now this guy is going to be
in our world for a minute.
I don't like hearing about as calm.
Do you? I don't like the calm at all.
That part really freaks me out.
What?
You liked that part? Math
Dick Guy. This is on the list.
Oh,
my fucking head hurts.
More calm than I've ever done in my mind.
And I know you get blowjobs.
Yeah,
I'd pay you what?
I cannot wait.
So back that been hot and Horny home,
man. If I lay anybody off second,
get me a blow job.
That's nice.
Really Nice thing.
The best part is right here though.
Okay. Okay. Just, yeah, I know.
Believe me, my brother didn't
go when he smoked with me.
He put his Dick can't
believe how big his dick was.
He jacked off for by and shot the most.
Come here every time.
It's like he's only 49 and he's fine.
He has no neuropathy problems at all,
but his day gets even harder and thicker
and even more coming believes me now
brother,
when they were smoking meth together,
nice testimonial.
Well my brother did it and then his
dad got hard and he jacked off in four
strokes. That's the skies
testimonial for smoking meth.
I mean you want to see some come
watch my brother Jack his dick. God,
it's terrible. What kind of
endorsement is this? Well,
he's saying like you want
a credible source. Well,
my brother smokes Beth with me. His deck
get so hard, he can barely not come.
He pulled his big
babe.
His brother jerked off in front of him
and he came in for strokes.
It's so disgusting. It's true.
This guy is so fucking fucked up.
This might be the most fun.
I don't know.
It's a close tie between the piss on me,
beat me gay and then watching your
brother Jack, his Dick in front of you.
Here's the difference.
I think the Piss on me beat me guy.
Why he trumps this guy is because he
just smoked right before we made that.
So you're seeing a guy in his manic
super high state. There's like,
here's the deal myth.
He's laying with his fuck.
Come over here. This guy is actually
not high right now. And that kind of,
I mean, that could take this video
from an eight to a 10. Oh yeah.
If he had done this video. Hi. I agree.
I wish you would've been more hot dot.
Now this is a big problem
in the gay community is uh,
smoking math and doing
gay sex. Yeah. Yeah.
Because they don't use protection in San
Francisco. It was a big, our guest, right?
It is our guest. Oh, okay. Let's
take a quick break. Oh my God.
An SF. This was a big problem.
It's like a quick break. Okay.
I want to talk about it though.
All right.
Our guest isn't here yet, but
false alarm. We can, yeah,
we can still play with this
guy, thankfully. Thank God. God.
So what's the hat? He's wearing
a, it looks like the, um,
the rim that used to be
snug is all open now. Right.
This has to be one of the
weirdest ones we've ever gone.
I just want to revisit what
happened with his brother.
Believe me when he smoked with me,
but at his dick,
I can't believe how big his dick when
he checked off for drove shot the most
common,
every shot 49 the Roxy problems at all.
But he's dead. Gets even harder
and more coming. Believes me now.
Who is part of his charm?
I think he's in a public place.
Do you hear the background noise?
I think he locked himself
in like a bathroom stall at
a restaurant and he's like,
I got to share this with work.
I'm serious.
Cause he's like, yeah, my
brother shot. He's like,
keep telling you it's sweet secret.
Have what?
A weird thing like and
my brother shot come.
I watched it and I want big,
his Dick was,
he dragged off in four strokes.
You realize too that his brother didn't
give in on this request the first time.
His brothers like,
you know,
you keep asking me to smoke meth and
jerk off with you and today's your
birthday.
I'm 49 I'm going to do it.
It's probably year or sometimes
just beating them down like, dude,
are you going to fucking smoke meth
and jerk off? All right. God dammit.
No, not here doing anything illegal. I
don't want you to do anything illegal.
I know what you're doing.
Anything you don't feel comfortable doing.
If you can find anybody you
know that won't get you into
trouble, smokes and man,
the more you smoke up that bow
hardier depot, get your big globe
from Olympic too hard deck.
I will do it this weekend and I'll
videotape it from this. A small deck,
very lamp and watch it and get harder and
harder. That's a prison factor, right?
Let me know. That bothered me a bit. If
you say yes, I'll show it to you. Yeah,
it's okay. No blue band. Where's
the, where's the followup video?
Just going to send me this teas
and not follow through due to now.
It makes sense why this was a thing in
the gay community when I lived in SF,
because they would have billboards like,
hey guys,
don't smoke math on but fuck.
Because what happens is you get all hopped
up and then you don't have a condom,
you don't use condoms.
And it was like it was bad for them.
I think it's not just something
bad for the gay community.
I think this is for the all all
decks community. Anyone with a Dick,
no matter where you want to
put it could be. It could make,
I mean if I smoked meth
and I'm like this guy,
I feel like I could have problems
too. You know? It's a lot. It's a lot.
I wonder why.
So this is a question for the doctor or
like why does the math make your dick so
hard? That's why I love this shit. It
makes it so hard. It's why the Benadryl,
that guy loved it too much.
Are you going to try this now? Now
look in your eye like I could go there.
No, I couldn't. Yeah, you
kind of want to do the meth.
Don't get once. No, no. Just
to see what would happen.
It is appealing when you, when
you hear somebody say, you know,
yeah,
kid becomes hope sensitive.
You know,
that's nice,
but you don't need lube
or no bed or nothing.
Hot White Come,
oh my God,
guys are so fucked up,
Jane guys are,
I've never seen a video of a woman
doing something like that being, ah,
it makes my pussy so away.
Well, we played one or two,
but they were real crazy looking
at the old ones aren't even there.
I think all of them are
crazy. Like, yeah, they were.
You won't believe how good it
feels. Good. You're straight.
You won't believe how good it builds.
You're declared becomes hope
sensitive that you don't need lube.
You don't need spit.
You just
do it and you would shoot and
enormous amount of Dick Dick
hot fucking BARF.
Can you turn it off?
He's so nasty. Is the nastiest
mother firearm. Why did guys,
they all have to go into explicit detail.
Just like the Benadryl guy.
Here's what I want to know though.
I don't know what I would have
liked to ask doctor drew ready,
doctor listening is does this in
fact cure erectile dysfunction?
Well, yeah. What are we doing? Because
we're talking about all these, you know,
the silly parts of this.
What about somebody who's
like, I'm really struggling.
I've tried by Agra, tried
Cialis, I've tried injections.
It's not working. My Dick
slipped, but wanting to get hard.
Does meth actually help you out?
And then that will be one of the
medicinal values to meth. Yeah,
bring it back. Bring it back,
man. Try it out it possible.
I didn't know there was any positives
to math, but I'm glad there's one,
at least that we know of. I mean,
besides losing all your teeth,
which could be kind of good
sexually to scabs, scabs
and they do like to pick on
getting picking. Yeah. Yeah.
I've been around people that,
that I've been picking at their skin and
it makes me wonder sometimes. Yeah. Yeah.
That's kind of went out, um, a
style I thought really? Well,
it was big in the nineties and
um, you know why, right. I saw,
I didn't know people
still were into that shit.
We did remember we played that one really
aggressive woman one time who was like,
you eat that shit. And she was like
Super Aggro about it. She was a lesbian.
Yes. Yes she was. She was really
aggressive girls to eat my, yeah.
This shit. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I
do remember that. That was the anomaly.
That's not her. Yeah. Oh, here she
is here. I think this is her. Fuck.
My stoma is
so,
it's just so amazing that people's
priorities in their lives, like got guys,
I gotta tell you this.
I smoked
[inaudible].
Oh,
is it already there?
But then there was kiss my pussy and
the wells Fargo now was a different way.
That was great.
$1 million in this motherfucker.
All right. She said that she
had $1 million Bank of America.
You Chinese motherfuckers. Yeah. Yeah.
That was great. That's really great.
Kissing pussies. Yeah. Wells Fargo.
It's kissing pussy since 1782 there's
so many posters around your presidential
campaign on both sides that they prefer
not to comment about this. Yeah, yeah.
Sounds good. Yeah. That's my
tribe. But yeah, there's a,
like this guy really went for it
though. Hmm. Wow. The brother thing.
I don't think that's the first time
they've jerked off in front of each other.
I'm going to go with yeah, you think so?
Wait, let's do it. Yeah. It's kind of a,
that doesn't sound like
a first time thing. Uh,
those two are, yeah. You want to, um,
by the way talking about the fact that Oh,
uh,
the cause the cause is locked up now.
He's not locked up. He's going to be sent,
but he's got convicted.
That's fantastic news.
I wish they would get the other creeps.
I feel like wines,
Weinstein and uh,
Matt Lauer and a sea crest.
And who else?
Dustin Hoffman. Do you remember Kevin
Spacey? None of these guys get locked up.
Was last time when he was walking
out of court. This crazy shit.
Huh?
Fucking real. For those of you who
are just listening to the show? Yeah.
So is planning a clip of Cosby walking?
This is out of court.
So He's been through it all day. Yeah.
And this is, this one's from a while ago,
I mean the same trial, but I think
the, the first time they had a trial,
um, that that resulted in a
hung jury and he's walking out,
it's a very serious matter.
It's very serious
Mike. I mean, you're coming
out of court. Yeah. And it's a,
you should look somber and worried.
Okay. That's kind of crazy.
But the latest so crazy
is that he was convicted,
at least fake is convicted.
He's facing 10 to 30 years in prison.
This is leaving the court
house headed to his vehicle.
And I don't know,
just keep an eye on the cause.
Philadelphia home 14 years ago,
a couple of key
he's doing his stupid
fucking dance moves dude,
is just stick on the way you just
got convicted in prison. He's like,
he's like, I'm bad. I'm
doing what the cars will be
playing. I have a Obama. Yeah.
Yeah.
Talk about
three counts of aggravated and decent
assault stemming from allegations that he
drugged and molested Andrea constand in
his suburban Philadelphia home 14 years
ago.
Unbelievable.
Talk about a true
sociopath. Yeah, he's crazy.
He's so removed emotionally from
what's happening. Like he did.
It doesn't take this seriously at all.
I'm surprised he's not afraid of a
judge saying that. The judge, uh,
and being like, okay, that's
really, it's a good point.
I wouldn't you be worried like,
gosh, maybe the judge will see me.
[inaudible] sentencing is
still to come that. Yeah.
And if a judge sees that
they're going to like,
this guy doesn't have this funny
when you left. Yeah. Hilarious.
He was making the crowd
laugh. Yeah. Yeah. Well,
he's still playing with the audience.
It's, he's sick. Uh, it also a dug up.
We played this years ago. My God,
the guy's Spn had him on, oh my God,
this is the best one.
And he was just supposed
to kind of tease the clip,
like a tease. The fact that there was a
match up that night between two teams.
One was his, I think Alma Mater.
This one's super weird. It's,
this one is so bizarre.
This is yours, right?
Mack football on a Tuesday temple.
Most of the bobcats of Ohio,
the call today from Bill Cosby,
Paul nine don't fiber.
But there's 10 hours,
the Ohio,
you a Chitlin legs
villas down here and tonight.
Ladies,
we're out of time and having fun
and you know that the ESPN, I'd
be like, thanks bill for that.
A completely sane renditions of
whatever the fuck do you think that was?
Because I don't know.
I don't know the actual team names.
I'm assuming Chitlin legs. That one was
a joke. Yeah. Yeah. That was the joke.
But also the bottom of a river that
was supposed to be, I think horns.
Yeah. So the idea is that it's if you've
got a live high school or college games,
right, right. Have like the marching band.
So he's like this is the temple owls
proper for such fucking nonsense.
I think I want to try to
do that and make it my own.
If I get,
if I get allowed to do that on TV,
I'm going to do the same
thing he did. Yeah. His eyes
are all fucked up there too.
He just starts to get blind right around
there. Yeah. I this way when I lag,
when I goes this way, when I goes
that way. And this guy's like,
what are y'all for me?
I mean,
he's checked no math and
you can get dick real.
Nobody's is checked out as
it's bill Cosby. I mean,
he's a total total [inaudible] off with
that guy. Absolutely drug him. Yeah.
He likes him sedated. Yeah.
Yeah. Dick oak is so hard.
You'll have pudding pops
coming out of the tip, so
stop it. I don't like his guy.
His cadences. He's creepy.
She reminds me of the Vegan Vagina.
I didn't like him for the same reason.
Can you believe it? He's,
he's as checked out as Oj was.
Remember when Oj got arrested and he
said, yeah, well my mission from now on,
I'm going to find the killer. I'm going
to find the person who killed Nicole.
I think we did
asshole. Tell me what might have
happened on the night of June 12th,
1900 and let's just walk through
them. Well, first of all, it's,
this is a very difficult,
I'm going to do this. Yeah.
Difficult for me because
it's hypothetical. I know,
and I accept the fact that
people will not feel whatever.
What are they gonna fit,
you know? Uh, wow. Uh, um,
nailed something. Whatever.
Whatever they want to feel.
Huh?
I mean, a book, the hypothetical
is Charlene a pulse that
laughing.
This guy shows up.
The guy we had recently
become friends with and uh,
I don't know why you had been
buying them Cole's house,
but it told me you wouldn't
believe what's going on over.
You've put on, well, captain gloves. Uh,
this is hypothetical.
I'll put all crap.
The gloves and you're
reached under the seat for
a knife.
Yeah.
Huh. It's all, I mean, hypothetically
speaking. Yeah. Do you realize how much,
how difficult it must be for
him every day now that he's,
he's out of prison to know that his ex
wives Keller's out there and like, oh,
it's torturing. He's just trying to
be like, man, I gotta get this guy.
And we've seen him devote his, his
finances his time. Yeah. Fracking.
Keller.
Yeah.
He imagined that was the sociopathy
on this motherfucker too.
It's checked out as he is. Oh
yeah. He's Super Jackie. Yes.
The laughter and love the
goofing off stuff. Yeah.
That's the sign of a real cycle.
The C plus laughter and you're more
hypothetical. Would love to hear that
theoretical learning but not
car for the crazies and stuff.
Cause you can't travel with a gun.
And I remember Charlie saying,
you ain't bringing that I,
but I believe he took it.
Charlie took the knife
and the book. Yeah. Yes.
So the back gate,
you go through the back gate,
you realize that and it was open or
broken the whole time he's got a Nicole.
Yes,
we gay like hypothetical. And if you asked
them like a real question, he's like,
I don't know. Remember, I mean
I have pathetic. We don't,
some people saw this as,
as a confession. Yeah. That's what it
is. Of course it is. Yeah. But I mean,
I don't know.
Well anyway,
I go to the FARC and I'm looking
to see what's going on. Um,
and I can see that. Did
the peers, like Nicole,
I had candles on all the time.
She really did to keep our
overhead and music was on. And, uh,
while I was there, a guy shows up. So
Ron Goldman comes into the back. Yeah.
Okay.
I mean, you said she had candles
to keep her overhead down.
Not because she was fucking that dude
or cause she's like candles. Yeah.
Like people would have candles are
all like, man, he's electric bills.
What is that Tom? You study sociopath's
you love these TV shows. Like what,
what is happening with,
with he and the cause where it's,
it's obvious they've done
things they've been accused
of and yet there's so like, how do
I know? I just like, what is that?
No, I mean the, they just,
uh, they're shameless. You
know, they're like, they're,
they're ultra narcissists
and they're shameless.
So they do the thing that
they want to do at all times.
Yeah.
And they don't process any feeling
of empathy or guilt because they,
you know, they, they need to be
number one, they need to be the best.
They need to be adored and, and they
need to satisfy their own needs. In his,
in his case, it was more,
uh, I think, um, you know,
the jealousy and the rage that he had.
Um,
he had to satisfy that nobody
else could have Nicole but him.
So he went there and
fuck them up. And, um,
and with bill,
I think he excused his perverse,
really gross,
um,
choice for like a sexual satisfaction
because he drugged people.
Yeah. So they were comatose.
Like they, they weren't dead body
defied what he did. He probably justified
what he did and more than one way,
meaning that,
you know,
if the woman showed up in his
mind, he's like, first of all,
she knows what about she, she wants a
part of this just because she's here.
So that's part of his mentality
of justifying what he does.
Then when she has a drink, he's like,
man, I mean, his mind is probably like
there he's taken. Yeah, she's compliant
because she's drinking the drink.
It's the same way that pedophiles
convinced themselves maybe that like, Oh,
this child wants this because they're
coming over here and there, uh,
that he wanted it. They, they're
flirting with me. They, they,
they read the situation
completely differently.
We thought there was, you know, and
he might even really believe it.
There's an unspoken agreement between
him and everybody that he assaulted.
Oh my God. It's so crazy. Yeah.
I mean, it's totally different.
Obviously things that they did,
but they're definitely,
you know, they definitely are not
people that, that, um, feel badly about.
No,
it's true because narcissists can't take
any responsibility even on the lesser
scale, like not the sociopathic types of
narcis. Maybe the ones that raised me,
they don't ever want to take
responsibility for shit.
So you can be like, Hey,
remember that time you did x,
Y, and z? And they're like,
I don't what you're talking about.
Like they'll totally pushed, you know,
Amnesia.
Yeah.
And they'll find something in their mind.
Great that they did and
that's what they want to,
right. Oh man, isn't that a,
isn't it fascinating at the,
all this stuff fascinates me.
Oh yeah. It is fascinating. I mean,
the cause to it was, it's even,
it's different now,
but he didn't murder somebody,
but it's so calculated that
he had developed over time
the perfect cover to do,
juxtapose with what he was doing to do
what he wanted to do. In other words,
being America's dad being the,
it's even sicker that he's,
of course the suit and tie don't curse
was he's always measuring people about
cursing.
You're lecturing people about
their language and you're
drugging and assaulting
people. It's like, yeah,
he's the Dad, America's Dad.
That was the sickest part. Yeah.
Well that's because I'll be,
I mean,
maybe he's pushing away all the
dark shit in his world, Ryan,
and becoming the moral compass for all
of us. He can't handle his own darkness.
So crazy.
Yeah. Huh. Um, okay.
Our guests or guests, it's really here
this time. Okay. Let's take a quick break.
So we're back. Uh, we were smoking
meth. We were, dicks were so hard.
Weird came a real hard and,
um,
never done that before. Mommy smoke
meth. Yeah. Have you ever spoken to you?
I actually,
when I was talking about in high school,
um, you know, I was, you know,
I went to three drug rehabs in high school
and he's just smoke meth too as well.
Wait, you went to rehab because of
Meth, marijuana, math, LSD. You know,
the suburban drugs that we got at the
time. Three times. Three times I went to,
yeah. Yeah, yeah. Where were you
raised? I was raised in that little,
I'm in Korea at South San Diego,
South Korea. So this is San Diego.
When you are raised in San Diego,
right?
Yeah, Korean. Do you feel like, oh,
like the world has a lot of Korean people?
No, no, no, no, no, no. Because I'm older
than I look. Yeah, right. Like I, okay.
So I grew up in Minnesota when
I was a kid. You did? Yeah.
And there was only one Asian,
his name was Tom Roach and the,
and the reason why his name was Tom Roach,
he was the guy. Dad. He was adopted.
Yeah, of course. Come on. And he wasn't
full Korean because he was adopted.
What are you looking at it going?
I'm looking at the screen.
Don't look that way when I'm
kind of scares me. They're like,
I'm getting a prank or something. Okay,
sorry. So Tom Roach, what was it? Korean.
He looked like us,
but he behaved white.
That's when I knew about his white
behavior. Oh my God. He played baseball.
Right. And then like white
people, you go to his house,
it smelled like three
things. Coffee, baseball,
Nimitz and Pi, some sort of pie.
Rhubarb probably. Okay. Yeah.
Was He adopted? He was adopted. I
don't say adopted, I say abandoned,
but we haven't even done it.
Done a
proper introduction
because we've been rolling.
We've been rolling for a while
and, okay. Sorry. No, no, no.
That's how we like to do
a little bit a pregame.
And then here you have the great
podcast tiger belly with you.
Yeah.
Your name is Bobby Lee
and your lovely Khalilah. Khalilah.
Yeah. Do you want to have a last
name or say [inaudible] fine.
Okay, that's fine. Okay, cool.
And you also have your team at
my team here. You Tiger belly,
but they're not here.
I know the main,
but I wanted to shout out like Paul and
John. You don't want Ringo and George.
Wow. All right, so we've got the two
songwriters. I feel like you need George.
George was essential.
See Ringo could have fucked off and well,
George wrote like five or six solid
songs from the Beatles, but you know,
we were the main, you know,
yesterday. Let it be. Come on man.
Paul and John. Yeah. Yeah. There you guys
are. What make that happen. Of course.
Thank you so much for saying so Tom.
I enjoyed coming on tiger belly.
I had a good time. You know what?
And I enjoy you. I'll tell you why.
Don't can I tell you why I enjoy you? Yes.
I didn't knew who you were for awhile,
you know? Yeah. Are you talking
about, I know before though,
you know he was coming up like a
years ago. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Know I know who he is now. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Famous Thompson Guru.
But for years I was like,
who the fuck is this guy?
Can I swear this is the
question. Yeah, it is.
I bet the Cosby's in trouble
again. What happened? No, sorry.
We were in trouble. Like this
is him leaving court. Yeah.
Leaving court where you've been
convicted of sexual assault. Yeah. Okay.
Just keep your eyes on him.
Okay.
So he knows all that's coming up is
sentencing that he's going to do a minimum
of 10 years in prison for assault.
Just keep your eye on and lasted Andrea
constant in his suburban Philadelphia
home 14 years ago.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's Cosby dance.
Yeah. I have a story about him.
You do tell us and then I want to know
about smoking meth. Oh, got it. Yeah.
Got To get back to you. I'll
get back to that. But um,
one of my first jobs I ever had
an acting job. This is a back end,
like the late nineties. Yeah. I
had a makeup artist and she goes,
my first job was at the Cosby show. I
was an intern as a makeup artist. Hello.
I have the big fan.
I love Bill Cosby himself and goes dad.
Right. Yeah. Great movie. This is why
you guys are a great company. Yeah.
And then, um, she goes,
you know, he did the way
he took his hand,
he clawed my breast to the point
where it was almost bleeding. Right.
And he goes, there's nothing
you can do about it. Nah,
that's what she said. She said he, that
happened seriously. Yeah. And this has it.
And she told you this story years
ago. This is back in the 90s. Wow.
That's not a made up story. Yeah.
No, I, it may, it may, it may be,
but it's like the fuck would
somebody make up that story? Right.
But I knew about his vibe.
Yeah.
Then you hear things right on the streets.
So it's like,
you know,
whenever I got like if I got an audition
for ghost dad too, you know what I mean?
I wouldn't even show up.
I don't want you,
would you have not worked with him after
that at that point? Not at all. Really.
No. I, I can't do crazy. Yeah.
I got offered a show with Christie.
I don't say her name.
Just say that when it was Christie.
Fuck it. Allie Christie, Allie,
I'm sure she doesn't download this party.
And I got offered a part in
like a regular on a show for us.
I can't do it really good because I know
that she's crazy and I can't be around
bear witness to that crazy and realize
that every day. Another good question.
That is a very good question baby.
The very good question. Yeah,
but I don't want to
bear witness to nothing.
It's like I don't want to be
a witness to elect tragedy.
My mind 100% goes where yours went
because have you ever worked for crazy?
I know it's a rollercoaster.
You don't want to be on it cause you
don't know what to expect every day.
I just say press just by your confidence
and boldness and integrity to make that
choice. I also feel like being in
this business, if somebody was like,
Hey, do you want to a job on a show
where you're working with a lunatic?
My instinct would be like, ah, yes,
just because of the job and I
don't have the, um, you know,
the, the benefit of saying like, Nah,
but I think you do and I'm going to
correct you on that. Okay. I think you do.
I'm going to correct you on
that. You are Tom Segura, right?
I saw you on a late night show the
other day. Yeah. What was it? Cole Bear?
Gold Bear. One of the biggest ones. Yeah,
and when I see you on there I go look at,
he's handsome. He's one of the
funniest guys in the nation.
This guy's going to work forever so
you can make those choices. All right,
well thanks.
Now if you were like some sort of like
open miker and you were just coming into
the business, that's one
thing. But you are a franchise.
Alright. Alright. Wow. And you're a little
racist when that Bruce Lee's sweatshirt.
But that's fine. This is not, no,
I just really know
Brianna look roots of fight.
Who? I'm a big fan of.
[inaudible] sent a whole bunch.
You saw those boxes?
They sent an unconscious thing on Tom?
No,
just a Bruce Lee Mohammed Ali.
You had usually I should go change Allen
Iverson. And you picked out the Bruce.
I like a conscious decision.
Maybe cause you know that Bobby was,
who leaves coming here? Billy. Billy does
this. Should I change it? No, no, no,
no. You're fine with
it. I like it. I think.
I think you are trying to
make me feel comfortable.
I can get that side. You're going
out of your way to make me feel good.
That's good. This is a
perfect segue. First of all,
I'm not going to forget that
math gets your dick hard. Okay?
Order problems. I'm here
to tell you, forget that
bag or forget about south. Let's forget
about Dick and plants and all that stuff.
Yeah. I don't know if you believe me or
not. Yeah, that you'd like to see me.
Smokes meth with a small limp Dick.
The Dan get hardly any other way and watch
it get harder and harder than Norris.
Smoke harder.
My Dick get.
Is that your experience?
Yes.
11 it doesn't matter. We.
Let's talk a little bit. Let's
talk about the first time.
Can we talk about the first highest one?
How does one procure math smoke at the
first time? How did it happen? Okay,
here we go. Okay. You want
to go down memory lion? Yes.
I'll go down memory lanes.
Okay. To you? Yeah. Number one,
when I was in my late childhood
in May eight nine years old,
oh, eight nine years old, I was
like, yeah, I was glean adult.
I was molested. Okay.
What? No, I'm saying yes.
When you were, when you were 89 I was
molested by a guy with downs syndrome.
I do it in my act. Goodness. He's
serious. Okay. And then my guys, the guy,
I'm sorry, I don't mean his
20th I'm over it. Fuck man.
It didn't bother me at the time.
I don't think,
I don't really find your story
to be like a real molestation.
I feel like it was like a barter or a
trade system because you kept going back
to the same guy. Yeah. Yeah.
You're right. Well, that's
how they court you. I mean, I,
I understand when you're saying your
card or like you got something like,
I got something in return.
What do you get candy. But See,
my dad and my parents wouldn't give you
the other dips. Yeah. The dip stick ones.
Yeah. They wouldn't get me
at, that's my favorite one.
Foreigners. Right. Therefore,
he, yeah, yeah, yeah. That wasn't a
question. They don't do it on foreigners,
don't do it. No. Yeah, yeah. It's
fucked up. And so I thought to myself,
he has the dip candy.
Right. And I said to myself,
if I just, you know, all had to do is
like touches junk. Yeah. You're right.
I didn't have to kiss it or anything
like that. Just touch it. Yeah.
And I get the good candy.
Yeah.
So I went by like every
day during the summers.
And how did it get disrupted?
Like we moved. That's it. Yeah.
So you would have been still going.
That was really sad movie.
That's a good buy. The dip
candy I did. Fuck. Yeah. So,
and then my dad was an alcoholic
and he was very violent. Right.
He was a rageaholic as well. A man
alive or is he dead? Barely alive.
Yeah. Almost sad about it. I
love my dad. Sure, sure. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. You're gonna
love it when he's dead then. Um,
so with those two events,
as a young man or kid,
it drove me into doing early
drug use. Yeah. That's,
we moved at San Diego and you know,
uh,
I was maybe 11 and I
walked outside my house.
I lived in this place called Green Valley,
the suburbs,
and this kid was riding a skateboard and
he just parked it in front of my house.
It just to be,
he was there.
He flipped escape would over and he rolled
a joint and I walked outside my house
and I go, can I have some? He goes, yeah,
I did and I smoked pot and then I had
met a guy named Julio Romero while you
pointing at me. Literally
Helene Romero. Okay, thanks.
Yeah, it wasn't you. You're
provably Oreo, right? Yeah,
that's right. Yeah. Yeah. Cool.
You were a member. Goes a dude.
What's up bro? He goes, dude, I
got to go to Lucy's house. Lucy,
I told you about this
and so we could this lady Lucy,
she lived in Rancho
Bernardo. It's fine. Yeah.
Yeah. It's fancy. It's
pretty fancy and you walk in.
No couches in the middle
of the living room. Cool.
Was a baby crawling amongst a meth lab.
Oh my God. Train spotting. How
old are you again? At this point,
1112 Jesus Christ, man. And then that's
when I did meth for the first time.
And what? So that you smoked it. Yeah.
And does it hurt when you inhale?
It didn't hurt at all.
No,
it doesn't hurt because the
high is so good that immediate.
Oh yeah. And you don't sleep
for days. You don't eat,
you don't sleep for days and
you know the guy was right.
You do get erect it,
you get Horny,
but you're the things that you, the
only way you can, can I say calm?
You can say that. Yeah, I can.
Yeah. Ejaculations [inaudible] is,
you have to think of like really fucked
up things even at that age really.
So it's not just straight up sex, you're
thinking. So it starts off with like,
okay, a regular woman, whatever,
and your head. Right, right.
And then she's missing a breast.
Right, right. She has no arms,
and then like six hours later, you're just
masturbating to a foot. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. So it gets crazier and crazier.
And then did you do any sorted, twisted,
broken foot with blood gushing out? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Tom, yes. Sounds out.
Yeah. So that was at a one off and that,
or no, I did college. I did it constantly.
I stoled like 15 grand from my parents.
Save that.
Yeah. Smoked a lot about the law. Why
don't don't don't mention that here.
So you were 11. I know it said,
don't mention that you were sucking
dicks to, you mentioned that,
don't mention that hair. Oh, not on the
baby and baby. I know. I don't know.
But I wasn't even going to bring
that fucking vibe and well, this guy,
this guy was saying something. Tell
me if this is true or not. Yeah.
You won't believe how good it
feels. Good. If you're straight,
you won't believe how good it bills.
Your Dick Becomes so sensitive that you
don't need lube. You don't need spirit.
We this trip that dictated
this up and down four times,
it's this hot band and do it and you'll
shoot an enormous amount of very topic.
Dick
hot white castle. Okay. That's disgusting.
How do you find videos like that?
Oh my God. Oh yeah. He's one
of your, uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's uncomfortable. That's
not comfortable. Right. Is
it thick? Is it fair? No,
I have never heard of like
math making your calm thick.
Your promise thick from
not ejaculate a lot. Right.
So you might, he might go, you know
what, I'm going to do math in May. Yeah.
I say this right now it's
January, right? Yeah.
So I'm not going to masturbate
until May. Yeah. He's on that.
And it's all the explosions
in the sky, but it does it.
Now. Did you ever, um, did,
did you partake in crazy sexual
activity because of math?
See,
that's the problem with your mouth.
Sometimes the problem with your mouth
sometimes is blame it on the math.
Instead you're admitting to
actually wanting to suck dick.
That's okay.
But I don't even know right now who
listens to this podcast is the demographic
of your people might don't
get, don't, don't judge me.
I'm not, and I'm just asking,
you know, are they children? No.
No. Okay. Well then yeah, I did.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Our, our, our audience is actually
very empathetic. Very sweet.
Yeah. Very nice people. So I wouldn't
know. Here's a, here's the thing,
here's the thing. Can I just say this
and I just want to justify my behavior?
Yeah. You're on meth. Yeah. I mean,
I'm not a math every day,
once a month event. All right.
Acid. I did all kinds of stuff. Okay.
Yeah, yeah. I used it to get drunk a lot.
But the point is, you're not
as, you're not of sound mind,
so you don't have full
responsibility for a child. You know,
the don't feel responsibility. Well,
thank you. Yeah. That's what it is.
Then why would you decade,
but also when you're traumatized,
I swear to God, when you're,
when you start doing drugs and
you're traumatized, you're, um,
development stops at
that age level stunted.
So you actually are going into the
world as an eight or nine or whatever.
11 year old for like a decade. Dude,
I listen to fucking doctor drew.
I know you hang out with Bobby
for 10 minutes and you're like,
oops. Yeah. Emotionally. Yeah,
but can I just say something to your
fans and whatnot? Sure is, is that,
I'm 16 years sober now.
Congratulations.
And I was when I was 17.
I got sober for 12 years.
So big chunks of my life. I've
been in sobriety. That's great.
And I've done God's work.
Yeah, right. No gay here.
It may just not doing gay thing. What?
No shrimp now shrimp. Yeah. No, sorry.
Yeah, I've been a, I've been, um, I try to
give as much as I can. You're giving guy.
Yeah. And I want to be
spiritual, you know,
so people can listen to me right now
and go, I'm a heathen. That's fine.
Now there no one can repent and one
changes behavior. You Dad though.
Yeah. It's not your fault.
Your parents weren't on the list.
And let me tell you saying my
kid doesn't take a dump for a day
and I'm all over him.
If your parent doesn't know that you're
smoking math and you're out in the
streets and you're doing stuff that's
on them and they should have had, uh,
an eye on you, it's not your
responsibility. Like, how am I
gonna go?
I want to
fuck with the Dick socks start head.
Are you naturally good at it?
Cause I feel like, oh my God, I feel
like, I feel like as a guy you're like,
I know what I like. So you have like
certain skills, right? Well, it's silly.
I just want to say this to you and I'm
not going to go into detail about it.
Okay. But when you're young you
don't know what you like. Yeah.
So I think it was pretty much amateur
hour. Okay. You know what I mean?
I would probably be like, I wouldn't go
down to the sack where the taint. Right.
And Go. You like that. Right. I
think it was more like, you know,
licking the tip and going,
does that suffice? Right.
What?
Yeah.
Like if I am like how happy.
Joyful. Yeah. If I was never
a gay man and I was in,
you were gay and you and I were having
sexual out sexualities with each other
[inaudible] you and I would probably be
like, we probably know what we, we liked,
you know, of course. And we would
do extra things, you know, to,
to please ourselves. Sure. I would like
to please you. Thanks. You're welcome.
I like that. But yeah,
he was a kid. Baby kids.
The kids don't know how to give blowjobs.
Are you blowing adults? No, no,
no. Oh my God. You can't let it go.
Let it go. Kenya. And this is
your fault. Do you like that?
Yeah. It's your, it's your phone.
Like, so check this out. This guy
with his brother,
something cool happened.
I'm rather man, believe me, when
you smoked with me, he put his dick.
I can't believe how big his dick was.
He jacked off board,
drove by and shot the most
common with every shot.
He's fine. He has no problems
at all. It gets even harder,
thicker,
and even more coming.
This is a pretty good ad for math.
I think it's, yeah, but it's a,
it's a dangerous dog because
you can go fast. Yeah.
Or you start losing teeth
really quickly. Yeah. No,
because I didn't do it. I mean, when
you're in middle school, he fell off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I like 40th
crowd. I can't do it. No.
If I showed you the inside of
my mouth, it's crazy. Maybe,
I dunno what the fuck
you're doing right now,
but you're calling me out and
you're like exposing things.
I don't want people in those
days I can't use seriously. Yeah.
I want to say this. Okay. This is that
it on its own? Yeah. Can I just say
this? Good now I'm defensive. Yes.
Yes.
Right.
That I have a bunch of teeth
missing and I can't chew steak,
but I don't think that's from the math
and then that's because they don't floss.
So when did those teeth get removed?
It's been years of deterioration.
Do you go to a dentist at all ever?
I did. To get them removed? Yes.
What is your pain? Well, you know
Steve Simone? Yeah, his brother did it.
Brothers Lawrence.
Yeah.
Have you thought about replacing
the teeth that are missing?
They wanted to do metal rods into my arm.
Bone of your jaw.
You know how they did
implants and they screw it in,
but I just said life is
better with Maulers get these.
You should choose to do it now.
No, because I'll tell you why.
I'll tell you why I know because I'm fine.
Okay.
Because you can chew with gums. I don't
know if you know that. No, I'm not steak,
not, yeah, but you can chew
Brussel sprouts. You can,
she do everything up front.
Everything's, yeah, everything.
You go to Korean barbecue and you get
your Kalbi and you're chewing in the
front.
The front end.
I have a couple of like rogue teeth
in the back that you, that you know,
like I'll have gums on top bone.
Your bones.
Yeah. But yeah, I have that. But you
know what? I'm on a Sitcom right now.
They don't make it up. They
can't tell. Can I see her teeth?
I smiled like this and they can't
open your mouth. Okay. I'll show you.
But can I not do it in camera? Yeah, of
course. You're going to look down here.
Okay. Okay. Oh my God,
I don't up here. Wow. You
definitely can't tell.
You can't tell, but I'm surprised.
Uh, it just doesn't matter. You just,
why don't you just be
being around being real.
I don't know what's
wrong with you right now,
but like it just whisper into my ear and
then tell me you're going to be saying
stuff and then I'll go, no,
don't do that. Because it's like,
now I have no teeth.
You know what I mean?
There's so much going on right now.
I'm being offensive by the way. Yeah.
So, okay. Asians listen, I love him
and he thinks my people
are garbage. Filipino. Oh,
interest. I don't because
I know. No, no, that's not.
Your inner skin is kind
of a third world country.
Colonial colonial life. We never really
got a true independence. We're sovereign,
but not really. So he thinks Koreans
generally think Filipinos are shit. No.
Yes you do. No, we don't
all think I'm dating you.
Why would I think I'm dating you?
I don't think that you're a mud person.
There you go.
If I'm dating you, if I'm eating and me
doing it, sexualities with you and doing,
you know why he has a colonial
mentality.
You're like the Spanish conqueror that
likes to fuck the poor peasant Filipino
girl. I could see that.
Yeah. You could see that.
You can see that I'm saying that that's a,
that's a viable idea that she threw out.
I'm not saying it's true,
I'm saying it's,
it's plausible.
Can I say this song? Yeah, yeah. You know.
Okay. You two together. Right, right.
You know that, you know, you
know deep down inside, right,
because you're out here in the country.
Yeah. Right. You're on which lane road,
whatever that thing is. I never even
heard of that road by the way. Yeah. Yeah.
Right. And you know that this is
real love because you guys, you know,
have your character defects and
you're able to like, you know,
forgive and um, you just love each
other. Right. This was the same thing.
How could it be a colonization
kind of a situation?
Could you tell me everyday
my people are garbage?
What's what, what do you, what
do you think is wrong with,
if I do it as a joke? Oh,
what's wrong with them?
I don't know,
cause I've never heard anything negative
about Filipinos. Call it like what,
what are the stereotypes? Well, they're
more intense within Asian cultures, right?
Like, well, Dave, it, can I just say this,
I want to give you props probably
the most talented out of the Asians.
Really talented and what saying,
oh, that's true. Singing,
dancing. Yep. Billiards. Billiards.
Yeah. All kinds of stuff. Okay.
You know, and what are the negative
stereotypes about Filipinos?
We really don't know.
Yeah.
I think that we have any true innovation
in terms of like creating electronics
because that's what's, that's what
Koreans do apparently on good yogurt.
But what did, that's just the
Koreans thing and not, you
know what I'm saying? Like
I have a theory strokes.
Can I hear my theory? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. I think that, um,
groups of people that they have climate,
like the seasons change, what would they
go from summer to winter? Yeah. Right.
That they have to, um, create
more technology to survive.
So they're constantly in a mode of
creating things out of survival.
Right. And when you were at in a jungle
place, right. Which is beautiful. Yeah.
We go to jungles all the time. Right.
Why Aloha? Yeah. To you, my column,
I follow two of you in
front. Right? Right. Yeah.
It's just that they don't
really have to do that.
So they don't create know
that's why you don't,
no, no, no, no. You're, you're
logic askew because, okay.
What about like the inner weights and
shit? I mean, they don't have technology.
They live in Igloos and they
eat. I know, but he's saying me.
Is she saying that they don't have a good
day? They don't have a Samsung. Right.
And I'm shit,
but he saying that the cold weather
is conducive to people creating tell.
He's saying that the people that don't
have a necessity all you're all correct.
They don't have shit. I understand
that. Right. But there's six of them.
We need more.
Yeah. Yeah. If there was a
hundreds and thousands of them,
I think they would computers and no one
would live out on the Tundra like that.
That's a little ridiculous.
It's a little extreme. So do you
feel like when you're done with him,
you'll move on to like
a guy are just like, oh,
stay with it.
I told you that I would probably get with
like a east coast Indian. That's right.
Yeah. Indian from India. No, no,
no. It's close to New York Indian,
like New York Indian, native
American? No, like from India. Oh,
right. Okay. Sorry, just
to clarify, I mean, yeah,
but like like a Jersey guy or something.
You know, it's interesting. Max,
I don't know if I've ever met that Max.
That's interesting. Yeah, they're good.
Yeah. What's, what do you like about,
there is a different swag about them,
but not the La Indian.
It's all planned out.
This has been here.
What was it again?
You said your game was
when I started dating.
When you guys went on a few dates. You
said my game was, what was it like?
I pretend like he didn't know if the
whole Tinder thing where you're like,
is this working? Oh yeah. He's
like, how does this work? Lol.
That's funny. You pretend that you
don't know cause I get it every day,
but I pretended, I always pretend
like you're the first one. Yeah.
I don't know how it works.
That's kind of,
I would say high twice. And then the third
thing was it, did you say high twice,
right. To make it like funny.
That was pretty good one.
I like it. I like that. That's endearing.
Let me go to my agent question now.
Did you follow the controversy
over the prom dress?
I knew what I know about it. Yeah. All
right. So I could show their audience.
So here's the, the dress, this
girl, what's your take on it?
Is that, I'm going to throw
this out there, right?
I should, sorry. The
drama is that a girl, uh,
went to prom and she bought a white girl,
white girl,
a white girl, but I guess you
call it traditional Chinese dress.
She saw it was like, I want
to wear this, the prom.
She posted her pictures like
going to prom and uh, anyways,
somebody else,
a Chinese guy to be specific,
did a tweet where he
quoted it and we said, ah,
my culture is not your goddamn dumb dress.
And that thing exploded.
So then she's kind of in this middle
of this firestorm about whether it's
cultural appropriation and all this
stuff. So anyways, the old white,
so we have to ask Asians with the, I
have two things to say about that. Okay.
Number one.
The only thing that makes me mad about
it is she would never fucking Asian guy.
Oh, she'll wear our clothes if she
was knee deep in Asian Dick. Yeah.
Where would it be one. Oh really?
Yeah, but the guy with her was Asian.
You'd be like, oh, I would be like,
yeah, he's killing it. He's killing it.
Here's my second,
and I just thought about it and love it.
I just thought about this. Okay. In Asia,
this is how we used to
dress. Correct. Okay. Okay.
But this closing right here,
all the clothing I'm wearing right now
is more western developed. That's right.
Right. So essentially I'm
wearing western clothing, right?
Which is white people clothing. Right?
Right. So why is this okay? Right.
Are you culturally appropriating the
white guys? I know it bothers me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, I'll get, I'll,
I'll start with dressing like that.
You showed up like that, but that's
my thing. And also on top of it.
It's like the only thing that I had a
problem with like girls that were like,
look, I got a tattoo of like a
Chinese symbol on their body. Right.
And then they would never like fuck. Cause
they'll have, you know, are I get it,
are riding on them permanently. That
would drive me crazy. I get that. Right.
It's interesting that Asians
perpetuate this, you know,
they perpetuate it. They get angry
when something like this, this worn,
but they sell it to the masses.
Right. So if you were to go to Asia,
let's say for instance the, um, my, my
Indian friend actually told me this.
She goes, you know, when they were the
jewel in the middle of the forehead,
she's like,
we sell them everywhere and then we,
you're suppose you get
angry when people wear it.
Chinatown in San Francisco, they're
everywhere, right. So it's like our,
it's true. You're supposed to, I
guess. I mean to further that point.
It's like if you are,
if you the person are selling the thing
and I buy it to wear it, you're also,
you are profiting from it so
you have a win. In other words,
I gave you money to get this thing.
She gave him money for the dress.
So isn't that a nice exchange?
But if she was,
if I found out that she was a
Ku Klux Klan member, oh Geez.
That'd be hot right then. Yeah,
we've kind of hardly, yeah, but that,
that would have a probably
with that. Would you, do you
get off on the, I'm like,
how did you ever sleep with somebody and
the lamb?
Did you ever ask somebody to, to, um,
to like call you racial slurs as you had
sex or anything like that or no? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Call me Glueck or
whatever. Are there other, no,
I know you put some adjectives before
it call me pants phase goop. I, uh,
I just, I put out there, by the way,
that I hope everyone that's
given this girl Shit, uh,
gives Steven Seagal some shit too.
He's the biggest cultural center.
Yeah.
I met him once and he said to me 12 times
in a row and he didn't see any other
words. Nama stay, oh my
gosh. Did they go, hey,
this is Steven Seagal?
He goes, no, I'm a stay.
But there was other white people with me,
other comedians at whatnot
because this at mad TV, no,
it was at some sort of like billboard
awards or something like that. Right.
I hosted at one year and went
back when I was on that TV. Yeah.
And he met all the other ones.
You said hello, how are you?
But you wouldn't look at me and go,
Nama stay. Yeah. Even your culture.
And also I don't even know what
the fuck that means. He's, I,
I used to make fun of him
for this in my act about,
cause I used to watch that show a law man,
which was the reality show,
followed him around like Jefferson parish.
And he was so blatant about his,
uh,
how he would switch up for
different races. So when, you know,
he'd pull over black and he was like,
what's up with job at night?
Getting into sho nuff he would really,
really ham it up, back it
up for them. Asian people,
I swear he was like bowing. Yeah.
Would bring up martial arts.
And they're always like, I
called you about a fucking, uh,
there was a fire next door.
Like,
I don't want to get this conversation
with you saying you would happen then,
you know, with Latin Pete, like Hispanic
people, he would start speaking.
I know those kinds of whites
and those kinds of whites,
their heart, they mean, they mean
well, oh, that's a good point.
And you know that it's like
he was on a flight, right?
And there was this like southern
Asian guy next to not white guy,
me and southern white guy next to me.
And you could tell that he was
a kind of wanting to talk to me,
but he didn't know how, what angle,
because you can tell that he doesn't,
he's not around a lot of Asian.
Yeah. So he just said, uh,
my daughter loves hello kitty.
He said that to me.
If I did, I wouldn't be in the middle
seat. Southwest Airlines. Yeah,
it's true because my father is that
white guy. Yeah, 100% and you forgive it.
Yeah. I mean like I'm a, a
rant, like I get to observe him,
so I as an, I'm also as kids, so I
get, oh my God, embarrassed and all,
you know what I mean?
But I know his heart's in a good place.
If he were here right now meeting you,
you know,
he would only be able to bite his tongue
for a few minutes right before he'd be
like, uh, yeah. You go like, yeah,
Japanese occupied
and you'd be like, they're brutal people.
He just tried to get you to go off. Well,
that right there would be a, you know,
a fresh of breath, of fresh breath,
of fresh air. He would definitely bring
up the current news. Yeah. I liked that,
that the Korean occupation of the Japanese
occupation of Korea because that's
never brought up. People didn't
even know about that. So I would be,
I would be engaged. Then he'd be like,
look, chaps are nuts. That's, yeah.
And I would be like, yeah, they are. You
know, he would love that. Yeah. Yeah.
I've seen him do it. It's,
you know, as an ethnic person,
and I want to tell people this, you
learn how to survive in the world. Sure.
And you know,
I'm not as sensitive about things as
like other Asian people in show business.
You're also a comic. Yeah.
That's another thing.
You've been around dickheads for
30 year. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's you shit club owners,
I'm sure
saying stupid shit. Crazy things.
Yeah. Yeah. But you know what? Um,
[inaudible] oh hell yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. You've, you've heard
all kinds of, I mean,
shit in the parking lot of the story,
you've heard the wildest shit anyone
will ever say. Yeah, but you know what,
I give it out to, of course you do.
You know, it's like, you know, um,
like if a black guy kissed
me on the cheek, I go,
did I just get sickle cell anemia?
You, it just sounds like it happened.
It did happen. Yeah. Yeah. And
then you would like, um, I'm,
I'm also very touchy feely with comics.
I would grab people's junk. Yeah.
Which you can't do anymore.
So I don't do it anymore.
But back in the day you would
just fuck around with comics. I,
I'm pretty strong when it comes
to stuff like that, you know.
Who are your parents the
most racist about growing up?
What did they based, no, they based it on,
they owned a clothing store called fashion
Gal [inaudible] and it was basically
like, you know, Lane Bryant or
for ethnic people, so Samoans.
Okay. But every once in a while Indians
would go walk in and they wouldn't buy
anything. So I heard
that a lot. You don't,
by not being babied, they come in,
they look around, they look around,
they look around, you know what I mean?
Yeah. And you hear it, you're like,
all right dad. But that doesn't
necessarily mean that there are, you know,
cockroaches
or he did do a list of like,
you know, one time he get made a list of
like who the hierarchy, the hierarchy of,
Oh, who's not, who's at the top?
Koreans. Yeah. Well naturally.
And then who's second place? The second
war? Uh, uh, oddly enough Japanese. Yeah.
Really? Yeah. The Korean
to give them yeah.
Because they give it in terms of like
economic strength and their position in
the world and all that stuff.
Yeah. Number three was Chinese.
Okay. Okay. Number four
was, um, cousins. Snakes.
Yeah.
And number five was Mexicans.
They were like animals in between
it. You know what I mean? Yeah.
And then my black friends go, where
were we on the list? I got it.
Only lists was up to 100.
Yeah.
So they, you know, they're
pretty racist, but you know what,
my dad's on the verge of
death. Yeah. Yeah. Hi. Well,
isn't that,
but that's also generational.
Like I feel like, you know, we can't,
we can't shit on them. It's like,
that's the time they came up and
it's like, what are you going to do?
Change a 70 year old guys
life around his brain, around
you to this. I know you're about to give
birth. I know you're a couple months,
but I know, I know, but I'm saying
like, I know you're in this thing.
I know you're semi
happy in a relationship.
Let's say you're single.
All right.
Take yourself to a single place. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. It feels good. Right? And uh,
this guy sends you a video,
would you?
No. Shit. Here we go. Would you
go out, was this, would this play
for you? Basically? You know,
we call this outdoor
fuck. Okay. Walking Nate,
I'm tapped out.
Come on.
Oh yeah. Oh my God. Oh my God.
All right, well, hey, I saw
this as a public school.
A lot acquire was in public school.
Like dudes are just do this shit to you
all the time, right? Yeah. It's fucked up.
I mean, no one monitored it back in
the day. Fuck the ground. I got to say,
I'm just surprised. So
nasty. Uh, uh, the reaction.
I thought it was going to be real
problem. Huh? I thought you'd go with,
we're going to be like, what's his
number? Let me get it. It's like that.
It's never worked for him.
You don't think so? No.
You don't know that has that move
has never worked. You don't know.
But the why does he keep doing it?
I don't know why,
because I don't know why he does it all.
Just more on my dad is a nice living room
though. It's a nice house. Yeah. Yeah. Oh.
Oh my God. I like that. I contact her.
Relentless. Sure. Yeah.
Yeah, I'll do that.
Yeah. That's exactly what guys did in
high school year. Yeah. Joel Green,
you would just flip his stick
out and yes, he, Huh? Yeah.
There is a kid that would just run out
of the bathroom at my school and he would
rub his crotch and go, Ooh, I got
a boner. Like just stuff like that.
No, no. I actually, I'll be honest
with you, I was very, um, I'm very,
I was pretty Christian about
my stuff. Really? Yeah.
Because you have to understand
in high school I was, you know,
because I went to rehabs and stuff like
that and I, it's a low self esteem. Yeah.
That I would never behave that way.
I was more,
I would do all my sexual deviancy
and stuff in private, but I was,
when I was out in public,
I was so shy and scared of
the approval disapproval of,
of just people in general.
Yeah. I just wouldn't, you know,
I wasn't outlandish in that way.
Right.
I think a game time, you're pretty, um,
you're, you're pretty square that square.
Yeah.
It's only when I was 23 and
I started doing stand up is
when the first time I go,
oh, this girl wants to hook up with me.
Really? But it took that long. I mean,
I, you know, aside from the couple
of penises, I sucked as a kid. Yeah.
Yeah. And then aside from, you know, I,
when I was in my last
rehab in high school,
which is the Mcdonald's
center in La Jolla,
I met a Japanese man by the name of
Donald Jasta Wachee and Donald Watch.
He owned all this farmland in
ocean side California. Yeah.
And I worked on his farm when I got
sober it my senior year in high school.
And then one day he goes, hey, you
want to, you want to fuck, I could not,
you know,
like let's go to Mexico.
So he would rent out this hotel in La
Fonda. How I like Lafond yeah, right.
The beach.
And then he would have,
he would have clients from like Ralph's
and Vaughn's that pot vegetables from
him and he,
I was invited and so I would sit there
with these like CEOs and like these
people that own like with money and he
would Katelyn like just 20 women and I
was able to choose and I was
such a hard worker. Yeah.
That didn't have to pay for it.
Wow. You knew that was sober too?
Because I was diligent about my sobriety.
Yeah.
That there was like little gifts that he
would get to shout out to Daniel. What?
Donald? Donald, he hooked it up. He
did hook it up. So did you go to town?
I mean you were a young, sober,
like a horny kid. I mean,
were you just like, like a rabbit? We
went through like that. Yeah. And then,
um, we were pretty straight forward lovers
what you're saying, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I'm pretty straight
forward. I'm very Christian.
Christian about bring out all of
his deviants out of him. Well,
the reason why I fell in love with her
is because she was violent. I what?
I was really,
well, he was just really
Christian about his shit and he,
he put out a completely different vibe
in the beginning where I was like,
oh yeah, this is going to, yeah, yeah,
we'll come game time. He, you know,
he asks permission, can I kiss
you all that bullshit in this era.
It is.
Yeah.
But you know what she did?
Was she, um, she goes,
she smacked me in the face as hard as
you can. Really? Yeah. And then she goes,
yeah. Then she goes, put your arms
around my neck, so hear me out.
And then she goes,
tell me what you want to kill me.
And this is like two weeks
in, right. What do you,
and now this is where I expect Christina,
it'd be like red flag.
Yeah. Yeah. I would have been
like six times a day someone.
But for me it was like a spiritual
revelation. Like an awakening.
Oh, I went, wow, this is
new stuff. Yeah. And then,
but it's so funny with her is in
the beginning she was like that,
but then when she started falling in
love with me, now we're Christian. Yeah,
that makes sense. Yeah. Yeah.
Now does she ever eat your booty?
You guys ever gotten offered? Really?
He's not into it. I'm not
into it. I just, you know,
I'm not into giving it and Tom has
been begging me for years and I won't.
Beggar well, bag is probably, he's
always making his case, but I'm like,
it's so gamey back there. And I knew,
you see how big of a guy he is? Yeah.
Dumps or just gnarly. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hear them through the wall,
you know,
and I just can't imagine putting a mouth
on the bus because be compromised like
ass. Also known as talking this
out. I mean cleaning the kitchen,
playing the rusty trombone, anal Lingus
and Carlos sex is actually pretty simple.
Step one,
as your partner,
if you can any interest in me licking
your asshole the next time I go down on
you, how would you feel if I made out
with your butt while you masturbate?
I want that Lazy Maya. Yeah, right.
Her specifically. I, in fact,
I only want her to eat my ass. I don't
think I'd ever want, Bobby does. Yeah,
I think I'm with you on that. Right. It
just doesn't seem hygienic. Hygienic is,
that's where you know mean disasters
happen. The crown comes out. Right.
I think in the first year it
seemed like a novel thing to do,
but after five years together,
I don't think I'd ever put,
yeah, I'm not a medical
man either, but like, okay,
so even no matter how much they wash,
correct. Right. The rim. The entrance.
Right. Could be clean. All right.
Let's suppose they like did
a little analysis and they
found 1% pool in the ring,
1% probably,
and the wrinkles and the fall and
the wrinkles in the fall with ride.
The calamari part is what I like to say,
right.
But inside the walls of the inside of the
tube may be even the little bit of the
entrance, but if you go like maybe a
quarter inch in right, it elevated,
now you're getting 60 50% and at that
point it's to me it's like no thank you.
You turned down though, you
turned down an offer, right?
Well she stuck her finger inside
me once I'm, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Thank you.
And she goes like skinny,
like Iti fingers. So that's fine. You
know what I mean? But if it was like,
you know, Joe Rogan's to fingers, it
would be like, oh my God, that's a Dick.
That's a date which has your
diet. I mean, we had Sushi,
he had Sushi last night and it really
affects his diet and where he gets
diarrhea and stuff.
I don't get that really.
You said it was very runny.
No Sushi. It was just 40. And,
and they smelled bad. Right. Do you
go to an all? You can eat Sushi.
You guys go high grade, right? All right,
good, good, crazy. Come on dude. Come on.
No,
we splurge.
We go to Hamas and little
Tokyo and Gari. Yeah, like we,
we spent some Duquette's
top shelf, the Sushi man. Cause
you said you get Ronnie and stuff.
I've had maybe she stopped Nobu.
It doesn't matter where I
go, the fish, but I still,
I still go deep every time it can.
I tell your fans though how I
really fell in love with you? Yes.
Is it weird? Not at all. So I didn't, I,
you know, I knew you guys were married.
Right? But I didn't
really know him. Right.
And so I get invited to this thing
called the, um, what's it called?
Odd Ball comedy. Comedy disaster.
Right. And I look at the lineup,
it's Sebastian Dane Cook, and then I
see Tom on the line. I'm like, oh cool.
That's cool. I don't know him,
but I'm sure he's a nice, right.
So when I show up at
the Berbick amp airport,
of course we had to get our own tickets
and I'm, my manager only got me a coach,
but everyone else got first class.
So I had a walk through the sea of life.
And Tom was so funny because he,
when I was in coach,
he would come back with a pillow from
first class, throw it, throw it up,
which in my head I'm like,
oh, this guy's cool. Right.
And then apparently you were supposed to,
when you landed in to it,
I don't know what city it was,
Houston or whatever,
you were supposed to have an arrangement,
a car arrangement for yourself beforehand.
Of course, my people didn't do that.
Right.
And so when everyone got off the plane,
they just went straight to their
cars. And I walked out of my, Oh,
I didn't have a guy,
I had to take a cab.
But then I see Tom
standing there and he goes,
I just make making an assumption that
you didn't get a car arrangement.
And I got, I didn't. And he goes, well,
that's why I waited. You want to ride?
And, and, and, and I'm about to cry, but
I'm being real. But who does that
nice people on the man. I married
as a comic. That is very rare
to do something like that.
I, um, I'm selfish because I,
I also did it because honestly,
cause I was a fan and I will, that's
ridiculous. No, it's true. It's true.
I was like, I'm a Bobby Lee fan,
so yeah. But that was still like,
but also that you knew that I didn't
have a ride, which is that goal.
It's a clever of you. I put it
together. Yeah. But, um, that,
and then when he did that, those
gestures in my head, I'm like, wow,
this guy is legitimately a great guy.
He's the best. He really, really,
he really is, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Well you're the best as well
dudes in this business,
especially in Chavez,
were just talking about this
at the very top of the show,
how normal he is and how sweet he is.
And I want to say this about youtube.
I don't really recall people sets ever.
But one time I was at the Ice House in
Pasadena and I walked into the annex.
Right. And you were on stage and I think
you were doing new bits or whatever.
But I sat there,
I was,
you know when I walk into a room I
just kind of hear one joke. Yeah.
Paul was so fucking funny.
Then I sat there for like 20 minutes
and I had to go up in the other room.
I said, fuck it. I gotta watch this
girl. She's fucking amazing. Right.
So do you two together as a wonderful
thanks buddy for striking you guys.
My smokes a man. You're
very sweet, but no,
but know you guys are sweet people.
That's all we try.
Well you don't like compliments? No,
I think it's very nice. I'm, I'm a,
I think it's very,
I think you're a hundred percent accurate.
I've never heard a bad word about you.
Like there are people in this,
you hear stories like that
as if I can douche bag.
Have you ever heard anybody say
anything bad about Bobby law?
So I have some enemies that
term at all. They do. They,
if you just talking to the wrong people,
well first of all,
I'd love to find those people. I could
tell you who those people are. Oh,
give me their number. Well, I
want to hear them talk shit.
But there are people out there that
dentists that they don't like me.
You know what it is though. Can I
just say this? This is what Mitzi,
Mitzi always said to me.
You know, you, you, you,
you to become a star.
Yeah.
You kind of have to both people that love
you and people that hate you. Oh, 100%.
Right?
Yeah.
And so I'm not really good at trolls
and people like ripping me apart like I
want to show. Right. And, and you
know, when the show premiered,
people on Twitter were like,
um, you're a terrible actor.
And as a comic, you know, you,
you're a little paranoid when you,
I do acting work and ask her, I get
really paranoid. Sure. I know. And I've,
I've done movies, I've been
on a lot of shows, but still,
I don't really have the confidence
yet to say I'm a good actor. Right.
I'm passable and I've been, I've been
series regular on things, so it's fine.
I know how to do it,
but it's like,
so it's very like difficult for me
to read bad things. But you know,
in many ways it's just inevitably
going to happen and I just got to,
I have to grow past it. Yeah. It's, it is
tough to read horrible things about you.
I mean, who likes that? No,
but don't you find that the longer
you do this and you know, I mean,
I'm sure you experienced it too because
you come into it from not having
probably a lot of it
public three weeks ago.
Oh yeah. Tell him I think it's
even worse for me because I don't,
I'm not,
I'm trying to break in the industry at
all whatsoever and I just do a podcast
with him. So I'm, um, a few weeks ago,
some guy decided to take something out
of context about me and it became like
the number one thing on Reddit and the
headline was Bobby Lee's wife admits to
being with him only for his money. First
of all, I'm not married to this bitch.
Yeah. And I can tell them, I can sell.
It's not going to happen. Yeah, it is.
But that's all I'll ever be reduced to
is that because it's not like I could
ever out credit that Internet,
you know what I mean?
Like I could never,
yeah.
Yeah, you will. You can. And you will.
If you want to like it, it'll disappear.
First of all, it being not
rooted in truth that you will,
uh, out credit that, that claim
that's just internet, uh, gossip.
You know, it's like, it doesn't, it
doesn't, it's not like a valid source.
It's somebody saying something and,
right.
And so the guy ended up writing this
long essay of an email apologizing for
using click baity headline
and like, you know, but,
but she lost sleep,
sleep
over it. It was a devastating
time. I should blood for a
week over there. Yeah. No,
I really did. That's
terrible. Well, no, I know.
I listen in the beginning it's you very
sensitive to it and then you'll get used
to the venom and the poison.
Don't you prove it?
How it used to it a little more?
Yeah. Do you guys get that?
I feel like you're just the most likable.
My, my, my thing is just not reading it.
Oh Shit. Yeah. Yeah. It
helps not to read it.
Don't fucking look like if
someone had told me, hey,
there's this reddit thing and I'd
be like, great, I'm not looking,
I don't even read comments on like
Instagram posts. You learn to do that.
I don't read anything,
so therefore I don't get hurt.
Definitely stay away from youtube
comments. Don't even look at it. Yeah,
know you don't want to know
if you've looked it up. There's like nine
pages of how terrible I am. Oh my God.
I used to be, you know, and I
used to read them. Oh No, no one,
I haven't checked in 10 years or
whatever. But it's like, you know,
let's take a wipe subject myself to
that. Yeah, exactly. It was much easier.
Oh I hurt.
Okay.
But it was much easier in like the
eighties and nineties or sixties yeah,
of course a comedian because like you
could be on a show, you could be terrible,
but where are you going to read it?
No one says anything or they have to
write a letter and send it to the network
and you're never going to see it.
All the, the studio or whatever.
Much easier with that.
So great.
Have you realize these are people
that are unhappy with their own lives?
Whoever started that about you.
It's not about you.
They're just looking for a target
somewhere to put their anger and rage.
And maybe this person's jealous of
you and your beauty and your happy or
whatever the fuck. And it's not, and
not even to do with you man. Yeah,
you're right on them
because the thing about it,
would you start a reddit about
someone you didn't even know? No.
About a fucking pot? No. Cause you're
not, you're not a miserable can't,
this person's a miserable, can't
heal. But what makes people let,
let me just say that we wish, she said,
I know, but it's, you know, you know
it's going to hurt somebody's feelings,
but usually they don't think that she's
a person. That's why they're always like,
there's a level of disconnect,
right?
So you don't feel like that talking about
Bobby, the guy sitting in front of me,
it's a guy who was on mad TV,
a big TV show.
They don't think of you as,
as a real person. Right.
And you think about you are not in a good
place if you spend time creating that
out there. In other words, if you're happy
with like what you're doing, your life,
your dating, you don't go like, I'm
going to take time out of my day.
Ruined this girl's getting life.
You know what I mean? Like, so it's,
it's people who are in a
place that they're not happy.
You channel energy into that.
And it's like if you were happy,
you don't have time to do that. You
don't have any desire to do that. Yeah.
If you didn't care for somebody
podcast or work, you would just go,
I don't want to listen to this. Yeah.
And then you click off all you
would do. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Does it make sense?
It's illogical and I think it would be
easier if we knew who they were too.
It's like you don't want to know.
I don't want to know who it was. The
reality is you'd be like, oh wow.
Like this is a pathetic, no, we
get out who it was and what the
shy look she did research did,
went down the rabbit hole and we asked
her fans to find him and they found him.
They found him. And then um, he
wanted to come on the podcast.
No, he wanted to be plugged his
own youtube comedy channel. Was it?
Cause he's a troll. See he's
trying to profit off of it. Have
you, that's, you know,
they always say that thing that the person
that espouses that hate is actually,
they love you and don't
know how to say it.
You know somebody that that is obsessed
with you saying negative shit is
actually somebody that
kind has like a crush
on. You don't know how to channel
it so they go negative, you know,
comfortable with saying like,
I think you're the best.
The opposite of love isn't hate,
it's indifference. Same coin.
They're just haters going, hey girl, I
got extorted for money on our podcast.
You actually blackmailed, you paid. No,
but they said if you
don't send us 15 grand,
we're going to put this thing out that
I already said on the podcast that's
already out there. Right. And so I
just ignored it for weeks. Right.
We got a bunch of emails,
put it out.
But then what happened was I got a
commercial and I was on the commercial,
like just sitting there and the
lawyers came up to me and said,
can we talk to you a second?
And I'm sending that sitting next to it
with Jane Lynch because this is her and
I in the commercial,
right.
It was before like some good money and
I go outside like what's matter because
we've got a complaint from you.
It was that same person that was gay
went out of their way to call the ad
agency.
Right.
And to prohibit me from
participating in the commercial.
Will you give me that face for,
I'm not allowed to talk about it.
Did it actually stop you from
doing the commercial? No, they go,
you know what's so great? They said,
you know what, we're just kind of,
I mean we did get the complaint,
but we will also want to say that we
vetted you and we know that you see crazy
things and that, so you know, you're
doing a great job for our commercial.
We love you and thank you. Oh Great.
What's that? I don't know what that is.
Our nanny texting me back about our child,
but people go to great lengths to
fuck you on this thing. Yeah, man.
I feel like it should
be a separate diagnosis.
I think that the whole science of trolls
is really interesting and I think it
should be like a new,
um,
diagnosis and psychology
because they're faceless.
But there are like dads and regular
people who really live in inside the
Internet. There's somebody
doing that right now who
probably teaches at a school.
Exactly right. Yeah.
Taking it out. Well, it's,
when you think about it, it's such an
easy outlet. I'm angry. I'm pissed off.
I'm just going to throw my hate
towards a stranger. Of course.
Where's your baby inside? Oh,
you're a baby. I don't know.
I'm in the crate with the dogs. Right.
Good. Lock him up. Who has the baby?
Okay. It's, this is not your
first baby. This is your
second baby, right? I think so.
It'll be honest. You
have another baby, right?
Having his lunch pretty soon.
But does he speak English and stuff?
He does like mostly Korean,
but he has like, he has,
he's a boy. Yeah. Christina. Tom
said that your ex was um, Asian,
Chinese. Was he like the handsome
Asian or was he one of these
dairy?
I didn't even know it.
What does she say?
She said what was he a handsome good
looking at one of these are one of these.
I'm broken. I got fucked
up. He's very only Bible.
He's clearly,
he didn't have facial hair.
He couldn't grow it like that. Well,
there you go. Are you going to do the
no. Seriously. What? Can you grow
a beard? Can you grow a full beard?
Yeah.
I wanted to look like him.
I already told you my look. Right? In 10
years you're going to do the full beard.
Going to do a full beard, right? Yeah.
My hair's receding like yours. I've got,
I know,
but I'm going to grow the sides out to
my shoulders and the have the beard and
I'm going to have these like weird
like doctor strange glove glasses.
I like this idea and I want to wear
Hawaiian shirts only open. Yeah.
I want to be really Tan. Most every. Yeah.
That's the plan. Yeah. I like
your hair this length. It's,
it's good. God bless you.
It's quite nice.
You want to see somebody trying to scare
someone and they scare the wrong person.
I think it's pretty great.
Okay.
Oh, go ahead. I'm sorry.
Ah,
oh my God. That's so funny. Oh my God.
It makes me sad. That was
me. What would you do?
I go crazy.
Yeah,
I hate that shit. There'll be a,
there'll be a problem. Houses.
I don't like it. She used to do that
on an houses. No, she used to like hi.
Like I'd come home and she'd hide
and you jump out and then tape it.
I remember you did it like two
or three times and post it.
I did you post it over one time. She
posted that. But she has a heart.
She has a heart problem so I can't do it.
Oh,
that's not fair because if I do
a back she could die. No socks.
Yeah. Nobody answer your question. He was
a handsome, very handsome, a Chinese guy.
He was, I met him. Sweet guy.
Super Smart, super everything.
Korean girl friends are saying Chinese
men are the way to go with husbands. Yeah.
Yes. Not saying she made the
wrong. Tom's the best dressed.
But here's the problem with
the Chinese guy. I dated,
we were together for four years. So we
were serious. We were living together.
And then um, there was the, that whole
idea of taking care of the whole family,
taking care of mom and dad and everybody.
So I think that that put a strain on him.
He was really stressed out and I knew
that if we had a family that like our
children would never be number one.
You know what I mean?
He was always taking care of mom and dad,
the sisters and the,
it's part of the culture.
But how did you meet him though?
Because I knew her when they were dating,
so we were all that's right.
Open micros and then she would
show up when she'd be like,
here's my Chinese boyfriend and be like,
hi. How are you liking it? Yeah. Yeah.
It's all is just to, trainees
gets a fetish. Do you like it?
But did they break up before you made the
moves or did you yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got like, yeah, I got a phone call.
Like she's single swoop in there. Yeah.
Yeah. But did you like him when
you were dating the Chinese guy?
Uh, I was, uh, I liked
him as a person. Yeah.
I didn't have like crushes or nothing.
Yeah.
But then I always liked Tom because
he was so mature. Like when he,
I met him when he was 23 and I was 26.
Yeah. And he was just like a man, like he,
he would carry it himself like a grown
ass man. And he was so funny at 23,
like Tom Ziglar has never
not been good at stand out.
Like the first time he did it, he was
fucking amazing. And so I always was like,
that guy is so special.
Like you were so special.
I remember, um, that I
would go to your, uh,
that you use to run your show.
Tangier and those fellows. Yeah.
And like you were, you were the boss
lady at at that thing. Yeah, she was,
she was in charge. So you had,
I mean, you weren't just doing,
um, I always felt like, you know, when
you, when you fart, when you start doing,
you fart the first time, uh, when
you part, when you're doing standup.
That's funny. Yeah. No. And
you start standing up and
you're like, oh, this lady is,
she's running shows. And I was, I was
almost intimidated. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Because you go like, oh,
you're like a gatekeeper also. Yeah.
She's trying to make a buck, actually.
Yeah. I was trying to get out of,
we're going, we're going to day job.
Was this after MTV and all that? Yeah.
That happened in like 98 or
99 and I graduated and then
yeah,
I started saying so funny that you,
and you know who's similar to that
as the Oh yes. Yeah, but you guys,
it's so funny because you guys come
from that world that was like earlier in
your life, but you guys are legitimately
comedians and like legitimately funny.
It's so long ago, like 20 years
ago. But it's hard to, I can't, I,
I believe it's difficult to
reinvent yourself in that way. Yeah.
It took a break of that history.
It's like for me, I was on mad TV,
so it's kind of along those same lines
of stand up, right? It's the same lane,
but for you guys it's like,
wow,
you guys were really transcended the
theory that I was only able to date her
because I didn't watch.
Oh, stop it. Absolutely.
If you had been on one of the shows
that like if you were on one of the real
worlds that I watched and then
I'm like, oh, I think I would've,
I would've kept my distance.
In other words,
you're like all those tricks, but here's
the thing. I wasn't crazy. I wasn't great.
It wasn't like a puck.
Like I barely was
on the fucking thing cause I kept
my distance weird. Just just um,
feeling like, oh yeah, I, you know,
I feel like I know her. It's weird.
Like she is, I just know,
you know, not played out.
She's, I knew you're out there can deck.
So yeah, that's what it sounds like.
Hey. Yeah. I know you had quite the
resume when it came to that. So good.
I mean you were over there in Australia.
No,
it's true though,
because I did really work against me when
I tried to get an agent because a bag
then reality TV, we were
in the dumpster. Yeah.
People thought of us as like just used up
fucking porn stars. Really? We weren't,
you were considered shit. So, yeah. Now,
now you can have an entire brand
and be an a, a reality personality.
But back then we were really bottom of
the barrel. Even with me too though. Yeah.
Because
when I got off a mad, I remembered a
perfect segue, but it's odd because I,
I remember there was a movie called
dinner with smucks. Yeah, yeah.
Steve Carell. Right. And so Ken
Joan got offered a role. Yeah.
But then he couldn't do it scheduling
wise. So in my head I'm like, Oh shit.
Well he can't do it. I'm going to get in
and the casters or wouldn't even see me.
And I go, we'll tell them why. And
they go, cause he was on mad TV. Oh,
he's like a clown. Yeah.
He's not real. Wow. Right.
So, um, I had it, I had to,
there was a bunch of movies like that
where I couldn't even get in because of
perception. They say it's a perception
thing. Yeah. It takes a while.
It takes a while.
And,
but what happened was because of the
success of key and Peele Barron halts will
sass. So to a degree, all these guys,
they've shaken that meant mad TV,
you know? So I think it's helped now
things are great, but it took me a little,
very long time. Do you feel like
there's too many Asians working today?
Well, you know, the thing is, is that, let
me say something to you and then there's,
what were you about to say? Oh No, no way.
I was going to say is this though, is,
is that you have a point there?
What do you mean?
What's my point in May?
I'm,
I've never been threatened
of other Asian actors. I,
when Steven Yeun was on walking dead,
I was so happy cause he's number one,
he doesn't have an accident.
Number two is handsome and he's dating a
white girl in it or whatever. Amen. And,
um, I know him, he's a really
nice guy. You know, I'm happy.
But you know,
when you have more Asians but you have
the same amount of opportunity as you did
10 15 years ago, then it becomes
hard. I see there's more, yeah,
yeah.
Same amount of slots,
but let the same amount of opportunity
or more opportunity you're think,
I think there's a little bit
more opportunity for us, but, um,
there's a lot more of us. Right.
And you know, and also you're not,
I'm not getting younger,
right? I'm getting old,
but I'm so isn't the answer there though,
or the solution to kind of get
rid of some Asian people? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. How do you do that? What
you're saying? How did you do that?
There's no way to do it.
Yeah. Just kick them out.
The more the merrier to be honest with
you. Build that wall. So here is, um,
two deaf people, the pass
gas real quick. Okay.
Is this real?
Why would you put this in here?
Can I get you really just foreign isn't
the next round when he really stay there
for a while. I don't want to smell that
I'm pregnant. I'll fucking BARF. Smell.
What are you eating?
You're eating Kimchi or eating
all kinds of fucking nasty shit.
And you're Korean food. Does he
eat Korean food? Do you eat wild?
You know what I mean?
Like
the silkworms. No Korean food. I go,
I go high class with that shit. Where'd
he go? I'm a fancy Korean. Are you? Yeah.
I'm not like working class.
Correct. You're going to take
us, we talked about this.
Yeah.
I told you whatever.
You want to have any good ones around
the one in the valley that's decent.
Yeah. The Korean barbecue,
like dinner spot, like fancy
spa. I go to a place called,
I want to say what it's called.
Yeah. We've been there once.
I was trying to tell
him that we used to go,
we had that joint in k town when
we lived there on sixth street.
I forget the name.
I forget what it was
really Grand Kimchi trough.
You know when they put the Kimchi and
then the meat juices go into the Kimchi.
I really like,
is it that little mini mall where there's
a seven 11 and all that stuff? Yeah.
Is it?
Yeah.
I used to go there with the lady
would like the lady ate garlic.
All the flight attendant would
call it late at night. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know if this is the same. Sorry.
I'd have to check. Yeah, there's a lot.
I mean, you know all about parks.
You go there on Vermont. No,
John's great. Late at night.
She's great. We go there a lot.
He spit that shit when you're there.
What do you mean? Like if, uh,
if it's an authentic Korean joint, do
you drop it on him? Well, I can see it.
Like pop Duke is your sale.
Yeah. So can we have to rise?
Uh,
I can say Dr Gco going
to be stuff like that.
How about dammit mother fucker. Do
you know how to do all that? No.
I only know how to do like sexual stuff.
Like what? Like go to which that penis.
Oh,
don't go mark butthole.
Don't Jut is breast bogey is a vagina.
Dong is shit.
Don't bungalows far Pungo
and Chinese Pigou. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That's all I
remember. And then I know, um, um,
[inaudible] which is the n word.
Once more,
please
don't say it. Don't say it like that. It's
unconscionable
words.
All right. The show is tiger
belly. It is a weekly podcast.
It's a, you can download it every week
for having us on was this device, was it?
I thought we had a good time. What
did a great job chemistry. No, we got,
you guys need to come back.
And I did. This was good.
We should go to Korean dinner. Let's
do this. Let this be a couples thing.
So let's do it again. Uh, it
was podcast for sure. Again,
let's give dinner and at dinner I want
you to reveal more Bobby. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
now I feel like I can really learn from
you about being kind to your partner.
I feel like he is such an antagonistic
type of person that if I come hard or on
the offense, yeah, he just rains
down. Can I tell you something?
That's your dynamic and it is.
You need to keep that a provocation
and antagonistic side too.
You're absolutely, and give him
shit. That is what makes us look,
you guys are happy, but he
likes don't. Yeah, he likes it.
I feel like if I were to be
like a meek librarian though,
he would have broken up with me four
years ago. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
If I don't crunch his balls on a daily,
here you go. It makes it stick hard.
Makes us tick. How long have you
guys been together? Five years. Yeah.
So that makes her Schmeichel hard. That's
it. So it's whatever fucking tickles.
I know with him, if I get abrasive and
Shitty, that's it's not good for us.
The bare likes nice pets
and treats and stroke.
I take care of my bare that way.
That's my natural inclination
is to be kind and nurturing.
But he doesn't know how to repeat
doing. Yeah, it was a comic too.
So there's a fair amount of ball bus.
Don't forget talking about a
real math head here. So, well,
comedians also don't like intimacy.
It's very hard for us to trust.
There's no cuddling, there's no
beg for it. Check out tiger belly.
I'm going to plug a couple of things.
Yeah. Where else? Tiger Valley.
I'm on a Sitcom called splitting up
together. Nine 30 ABC Tuesday night.
Wonderful. And then, um, that's it.
You're going to have to hook up to
college football games. You know that.
What does that mean? Because we'll talk
off. Okay. So, um, yeah, tiger belly.
What's the show called? Splitting
up together. Putting them together.
Thank you for a, I love that sky. Great
time. What a delight. All right, we'll uh,
we'll see you guys next week.
Thanks for listening
Elizabeth. I'm fucked up. You got good.
Got Away
with that way.
I have a vague idea what
you were just talking about.
How could you miss this?
He got a sword. Shit.
Mom's house.
Do you better watch out for popped out
the motherfucking knock out real when at
your mom's house.
You Better Watch out.
He called up to pop out cause he
loves the most fucking knock out.
Know what I mean? And you
know what I'm saying? We what?
Know what I'm saying? What you're saying.
All right. What you mean when you ride?
No,
stay in your home.
When you see me in the streets
for the phone with the top dog.
No Buck.
It's trying to be your mom's phone
shipped.
Probably not spitting all the times and
all you other motherfuckers fall enough.
They're like, what's up?
What? The jeans. The jeans was
a loose and got fucked up,
saves my boxes,
trying to stack this cash to my bill.
Fold won't fall twice
as fast as for Christ.
He says he can't vocalize to a local guy
who got fried with the wrap on a track.
Like
it ain't no surprise,
but the wax of the pig,
I'm gonna fill out like a motherfucker.
Put some respect on Monday
and I don't mean no direction at all.
Feeling like Steven Seagal.
Linkedin itself will shit,
Bro.
You know where I'm at,
right? The fuck. Why I
need to be Bob's house.
You Better Watch out.
Hold up.
Popped out crazy blogs to my fucking
knock out real scowling at your mom's
house.
Tell you that he better watch out
because he loves the
motherfucking fucking knock out.
And you know what I'm saying?
You Ain't
know what I'm saying. What you saying?
What you mean when you're riding them them
when you see me in the streets.